>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>>Karen Jaffe: Good
morning, everybody.
>> Good morning.
>>Karen Jaffe: Who here is
from Star Elementary School?
Everybody.
In the kindergarten class, right?
Welcome, welcome to the
Library of Congress.
How many of you have been to
the Library of Congress before?
Wow, that's great.
I'm Karen Jaffe and I am
the director of this place
in the library, called
the Young Readers Center.
And it's a place just for children.
The Library is very
big and very old.
Over 200 years old.
That's right.
But we are only 6 years old in
these rooms, three rooms here
at the Young Reader Center.
And today the Young Reader Center is
bringing a special program for you
in conjunction with an organization
called the European Union,
which is made up of 28
countries, very far away,
across a big ocean in Europe.
And we are very excited to
have a puppeteer from Bulgaria
and that's a map you'll see
a little bit when you leave.
You can come around and
look at the map of Bulgaria.
And that is where she is from.
Her name is Julia --
I'm going to make sure
that I'm pronouncing this
correctly -- Tasheva.
Tasheva. Julia Tasheva is here.
And I'm going to introduce her
and she's going to put on a show.
Okay, Julia.
[ Music ]
>> JULIA TASHEVA: Hello, everyone.
>> Hello.
>> Do you see Bulgaria on the map?
>> Yeah.
>> JULIA TASHEVA: It looks like
the United States, but just tinier.
Okay.
[ Music ]
>> JULIA TASHEVA: Okay, I think
now it's time to spin a yarn.
Until the little story.
How we call this instrument?
Accordion.
Do you see.
I was playing on the accordion.
And how we're going
to spin the yarn,
they use this little tool
we call spinning wheel.
[ Music ]
And now I would like to
tell a story, a little story
of children made out of yarn.
A boy and a girl, made
out of white and red yarn.
Let's see now.
In the old church house, in a woven
basket lived two bowls of yarn.
The first one was white,
pure white, as it had slept
in the snow bank in the snow.
La la la la la la.
And the second one was bright red
and it had melt down from the sun.
There were leftovers from one pair
of [speaking foreign language].
You know what [speaking
foreign language]?
Those are slippers.
We call in my country Bulgaria
[speaking foreign language].
Tap, tap, tap, tap.
It's for the little feet.
[speaking foreign language]
made of white
and red yarn made for Christmas.
But Christmas had long past and
the gloomy fire, [mumbling],
was melting in the grate.
And the icicles were dripping down
and the drains down boom, boom.
Oh, and the news spread
all over the streets.
With the first flight of birds from
the south this coming great spring.
Oh, with the first
flights of birds is coming
from the south the greatest spring.
With the first flights of birds
is coming the greatest spring.
Oh. What, oh, somebody [inaudible].
No, no, no.
But what did I do now that spring
is coming, who will warm up now.
Oh, no, no, no.
What we going to do now?
I've barely enough to make
a jack and forest apparel.
Oh, well, not just to
make a -- let's see.
What, you don't have enough
to make anything though.
I'm great enough to
make a hat for a frog.
Oh, but what are we going
to do now, spring is coming.
Nobody will give [inaudible].
Well, ahhh.
Ahhh. Ahhhh.
Shhhh, hey, hey, hey,
whoa, someone is coming.
Go hide. This way.
This way. Oh, I don't hear anyone.
Shh, wait.
I don't hear anybody.
I told you hide.
Go in the chest.
Oh, okay, let's go.
Jump, jump.
Good. Hey.
Okay.
[ Kids Laughing ]
Let me see who's coming.
I didn't hear anyone coming,
so let me see out here.
Nobody. Maybe over there
from the door we can see.
Oh. I know, I know who is here.
I know everything about her.
She wears what?
[speaking foreign language].
Can you say pa-lee-che-ta
[phonetic spelling].
Bravo. And what do we have here?
Oh.
Let's see.
>> What is it?
>> JULIA TASHEVA: I
don't know we'll see.
One sleeve.
Another sleeve.
Oh. Who am I?
Let's see.
This way, this way,
oh, this is pretty.
What? Huh?
Here I am.
I'm an old looking lady.
Okay. The spring is coming and I
have to clean everything around.
Let me see.
Oh. Clean the carpets and blankets,
my grandchildren are coming
and they're going to
start running around,
so I have to clean around it.
Blanket. Here, and there.
And over there.
Good. Good, good, good.
>> And over there.
>> JULIA TASHEVA: And over there.
>> JULIA TASHEVA: Now it's good.
Okay.
[ Speaking Inaudibly ]
This beautiful blanket
for the spring is coming.
We going to turn around.
[ Kids Laughing ]
Woo, beautiful isn't it?
>> Yeah.
[ Inaudible Speaking ]
>> JULIA TASHEVA: The sun comes out.
Oh.
[ Inaudible Speaking ]
March is here.
March, my friends,
is my favorite one.
Because my name is Martha.
I am Babba Martha.
Okay. But did you hear
the news, the big news?
Did you hear the news?
Well, the news is that from
the first flight of the birds
from the south is coming in spring.
Yes, with the first flight.
Oh, but my children are coming, I
have to give them some presents.
What should I do for them?
What presents should I
give them for the spring?
Oh, oh, yes, yes.
Do you know which of the
first flowers of spring?
Do you know?
which is -- no, no, no, I had
something in mind already.
I'll show you.
The first flower of spring
is called a snow drop.
Have you heard of the snow drop?
>> No.
>> JULIA TASHEVA: Snow drops.
Here are the snow drops.
We call them in Bulgaria
cokichek [phonetic spelling].
>> Cokichek.
>> JULIA TASHEVA: Very good, bravo.
Cokichek. Everybody say, Cokichek.
>> Cokicheck.
>> JULIA TASHEVA: Wonderful.
Okay, I think I'm going
to make a little bouquet
for my granddaughter and grandson.
They'll love the cokichek.
[ Singing ]
Snow drops.
You remember now?
Here, and then come
and surprise them.
Oh, you know what I'm thinking,
I think I should make
some present [inaudible]
so they can remember
for long time, right?
something else.
Yes, yes, yes.
I have an idea.
I think I have left
some balls of yarn.
Oh. What am I saying,
they are so tiny.
I cannot even make a pair
of [speaking foreign
language] for a doll.
What should I do.
But the string is spun.
Let's see.
What we can do out of those?
I think from the red one I'm going
to make for my grandson a boy.
A hero with a red hat and a
red belt and little red shoes.
Yes, yes. Let me see.
Let's see if I can fix it here.
Here is the boy.
And for my granddaughter I'm
going to make a little girl
with braided hair like mine.
I'm going to braid the hair.
Okay and a beautiful
dress is a snow drop.
Oh, how we should call them.
Let's see.
I think I will call them Pejo
[assumed spelling] and Panda.
Okay, you say, Pejo and Panda.
That's what we going to
call them, Pejo and panda.
They will love each other like my
grandchildren loving each other.
Yes.
[ Music ]
Something happened, let me fix.
I'm sorry.
[ Music ]
It's not this one.
Now it's going to work.
A little technical problem.
The [inaudible] doesn't
work, I'm sorry, again.
[ Music ]
Doesn't know how to [inaudible].
Watch now.
Here. Take a seat.
[ Music ]
Got tired.
[ Someone Yelling ]
>> JULIA TASHEVA: Who's calling.
[inaudible yelling].
Somebody's calling.
Let me see, which one.
You wait for me here.
Who's calling here.
[inaudible yelling].
There's a giant trapping in the sky.
'
[ Inaudible Speaking ]
>> JULIA TASHEVA: Big
trouble, big trouble.
Big trouble.
Big trouble, big trouble.
The spring is in trouble.
There's a big giant
trapping in the sky
and the spring cannot
come down in the town.
Oh, big trouble, big trouble,
what are we going to do now.
oh, the neighbors and people went
outside to see what's going on
and to see the news all over.
Big trouble, big trouble.
Did you hear the news?
The spring is in trouble.
Did you hear that.
Yeah, big trouble.
Oh, big trouble, big trouble,
the spring is in trouble.
What are we going to do?
We're going to go outside.
What's going on, where's the
trouble, what is this fuss.
Who's calling [inaudible].
Big trouble, big trouble,
the spring is in trouble.
There's a giant trap in the
sky and she cannot come down.
Oh, be careful.
Did you see the big
trapping in the sky?
Which way did she go,
which way did she go.
Wind, oh, where, oh, hey,
be careful, be careful.
The storm to lead us
the way we have to go.
I don't know.
Oh, okay, go this way.
No, no, not this way,
this way, this way.
Stop, stop, stop, stop.
Whoa. Which way to go.
Somebody needs to solve this problem
so we can find -- fix this mess.
Find where is spring.
Let's see.
No, no, no.
we have to go and find another way.
Who's going to help,
who's going to help.
Who? Hey. [speaking inaudibly].
Let's go. Brave Pejo
and Panda decided
to help and solve the problem.
Okay. We should go that way.
No, let's -- okay,
let's go this way.
okay. and nobody -- look, look,
look, kids made out of yarn
and the boy has a little
[inaudible] hat made out of yarn.
Okay, which way we should go.
Hey, where are you going?
We are going to find the stork and
we are going to see the spring.
Oh, okay, go.
Thank you.
This way. Here, here, here.
The way they got lost,
because the stork --
The stork got hungry.
And stopped by the pond to eat.
Mmm, yummy.
Oh, a little further, bloop.
Mmm.
And he fell asleep.
>> What did he eat?
What did he eat?
I think he ate -- I
know what he ate.
>> JULIA TASHEVA: the wind, also --
Fell asleep in the field.
I'm tired.
And now Pejo and Panda, [inaudible].
What do you see?
It's dark.
Hey, hey, hey, no, no, no, no, no,
you're not sleeping,
we have stuff to do.
Wake up, wake up, wake up.
What? Quick, get up, get up,
get up, we have to find spring.
And all our friends, okay.
Yes, okay.
Okay, now get ready.
Oh, yes, you can hang on me.
Hey. Okay.
Hang on. Let's go.
This way, this way.
Okay, okay.
[ Music and Singing
in Foreign Language ]
Hey, get up, get up,
get up, get up, get up.
Go, go, go, go this way.
Hey, go that way.
no, no, no, this way.
no, no, no.
woo. Oh. Yeah, yeah,
yeah, I can see her.
Stop, stop, stop.
Here. Yeah.
In the spring [inaudible].
[ Music ]
I have to put on my new dress.
I'm so glad to be back here.
It's springtime.
[ Music ]
You know the flowers [inaudible].
It's orange.
What is this color?
Purple. And what is this color?
White.
[ Music ]
There's some flowers in the yard.
Three.
four.
[ Music ]
Five.
And the tree, what they
do in the springtime,
the trees are blooming, right?
With flowers and the
cherry blossoms.
[ Music ]
>> There's still some more.
>> JULIA TASHEVA: Spring
had arrived.
It's so beautiful now, right?
>> There's more.
One, two, three, four.
[ Music ]
>> JULIA TASHEVA: I have
to go to the other town.
[ Music ]
[ Inaudible Speaking ]
Oh, wow. See how beautiful it is.
Oh, the spring is here now.
Hey, hi, hi.
Oh, how beautiful.
Oh, wow. Let's see here in
the field with the flower.
Oh, it's so beautiful from up here.
Hello. Can you see us from here?
I'm up here.
I'm here. No, I'm here.
I'm here. I'm here.
Oh, the people in town were
grateful for Pejo and Panda.
They found the spring
and they brought the boy.
And then they were nicknamed
maudeneachki [phonetic spelling].
Let's say it again, maudeneachki.
Very good.
The owner, the old lady,
Babba Martha, with warm heart
and skillful hands see that Babba
Martha always make maudeneachki
for everyone for their
health, love and happiness.
[ Music and Singing ]
[ Kids Chattering ]
Maudeneachki for everyone now.
Give me your hand.
And the first of march, Babba Martha
takes all things small [inaudible]
for health, happiness and love.
Always where that.
[inaudible].
Like Pejo and Panda.
You can save your bracelets
[inaudible].
>> No sitting, no sitting,
not sitting like that.
No sitting.
[ Inaudible Chattering ]
>> JULIA TASHEVA: You
remember my name.
What's my name?
Pejo. You remember my name?
Panda. Panda.
[ Inaudible Chattering ]
>> No, do not touch it.
No touch it.
I'm telling.
What is this.
Don't touch that.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.